Simon Kinberg isn't afraid to admit his mistakes.
The director of Dark Phoenix did just that
when speaking to KCRW during an appearance
on the outlet's The Business podcast.
Getting remarkably candid, the filmmaker took
the blame for everything that went wrong with
Dark Phoenix.
"I'm here, I'm saying when a movie doesn't
work, put it on me.
When a movie doesn't connect with audiences,
put it on me."
In the interview, Kinberg noted that it's
difficult to talk about Dark Phoenix in a
negative context because he genuinely loves
the film.
Ultimately, though, he feels the onus is on
him to take the blame for Dark Phoenix crashing
and burning with moviegoers and critics.
As for what might have saved Dark Phoenix
from its grim fate, Kinberg doesn't believe
that there's anything that could have been
done to yield a different outcome.
Would changing the film's release date yet
again have helped it?
Probably not, but Kinberg admitted that the
changing dates didn't help the film land on
the right foot:
"I always felt that we had a tough date for
this particular movie.
It wasn't made as a classic superhero movie,
it was made as more of a dramatic, intimate,
smaller film.
Originally it was going to come out in November
[2018], then it was going to come out in February
[2019], and those were the dates that I felt
like it actually would have felt more appropriate
to."
Did the massive box office success of Avengers:
Endgame, now the most profitable film of all
time, somehow impact Dark Phoenix's performance
when it opened June 7th?
Maybe, but Kinberg just can't get behind the
idea that another film is to blame for Dark
Phoenix's bombing.
The director said:
"Coming out five, six weeks after what may
well be the biggest movie or the second biggest
movie in the history of cinema, that also
happens to be also in the genre of superheroes,
was tough for us, and I always anticipated
that it was going to be tough to be in the
tailwinds of that movie.
But I wouldn't blame it on the weekend."
The tense atmosphere behind the scenes at
Fox following their merger with Disney didn't
make production on Dark Phoenix easy either.
Apparently, the layoffs taking place at that
time affected several of the studio's important
arms.
Kinberg continued,
"The marketing and publicity side of Fox were
very badly hit, and I noticed it because […] I
was going to marketing meetings every week
and there were people who weren't there anymore."
Kinberg also shared that he's actively trying
to keep himself from thinking about how differently
Dark Phoenix may have fared if it wasn't delayed
or if it had been better marketed.
At the end of the day, it doesn't matter:
what happened happened, and Kinberg is taking
it as a learning experience.
"I mean honestly, there's no way to know,
and that's the thing that I think can drive
people crazy and keep them up and be thinking
about a movie's failure years later.
If the lesson you've learned is that you had
the wrong date or you didn't have good marketing
— that's not a lesson."
Kinberg's comments here are refreshing.
It's not often that the architect of a box
office bomb comes forward and admits that
he should shoulder part of the blame for a
film's failure.
What's even more important here is Kinberg's
mention that Dark Phoenix floundering taught
him a lesson.
The film will probably do the same for the
filmmakers Marvel Studios, who will be looking
to bring the X-Men and several other comic
book characters to the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
In working out the best way to introduce the
mutants in a whole new movie franchise, Marvel
can turn to Dark Phoenix and pinpoint the
exact things not to do.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.